i mean at the end that's
another thing like that i think the
great entrepreneurs can look at a
problem
with very fresh eyes like almost
consistently and the
bezos described that as day one thinking
right like
just pretend this is day one every day
yeah and then other people use the term
first principles
but it basically means like when you see
a problem pause for a second
and really think through what is the
best possible solution here what are
some alternative solutions and get from
everybody like how do we solve this
problem and what people do sometimes
they get in a rut
they just come to work and they just go
through their email they do whatever
they did the
day before they don't think why are we
doing this yes and is there a better way
to do it
now you can get so obsessive about that
that you can over engineer stuff
and you can never actually ship a
product so there have to be some
pragmatism
and some goals and some dates associated
with that but
it is a very cool thing to really think
like
i wonder if we actually made the
batteries ourselves what that would look
like or
i wonder if we could get to two-day
shipping you know or
what if we do same-day shipping like you
need to have somebody who's willing to
say you know what [ __ ] it
let's set a crazy audacious goal uh
two-day shipping of any product anywhere
in the united states
and once you throw the gauntlet down
like that now everybody knows they're
rolling in the right direction
two-day shipping amazon prime and that's
what people didn't realize about amazon
the business wasn't the shipping of
those products it was getting you to
sign up for amazon prime
they have hundreds of millions of people
doing amazon prime for 10 bucks a month
i think globally it's probably cheaper
but that was the driver of that business
it was
all of those people because they would
you're an amazon prime subscriber
do you know how much you pay no exactly
it started at 50 and i think they even
had like 40 50 60
was like the testing in the early days
and now it's i think 149 dollars 12
wow 13 a month if you pay for the year i
think it goes down to 10 bucks
a month 120. and you're like wow and
it's like yeah you're paying 13
a month for the privilege of shopping at
amazon
yeah uh but you would you say it's the
greatest
thing in the world because anything i
need you know if you forgot a microphone
or a cable goes better a camera goes bad
you get it here you know within a day or
less
yeah it's pretty amazing
you